[Music]
delivers the rest two-point ball game
morrison to jokic great pocket pass for
the bucket
he is just lumberly smooth
oh he's i mean you can see he's he's
figured out things
and you can see it with your very own
eyes ladies and gentlemen
jokic meanwhile a little get back at the
other end and hampton who played in
australia last year came straight out of
high school
played professionally down there jokic
to the basket off glass
you can see that he's a lot quicker than
he was in previous years
holmes with 10.6 rebounds
and guarding jokic at this end joking
spins off of him
i don't know what you do with that
though well it's so difficult because
he is really backing up and banging has
to start paying
interest if he doesn't pay up soon oh
the rook takes time to pay back
i love it a little slow as jokic got
good position again for the bucket
coach walton would see him come back to
the practice facility late at night
to get 100 or 200 more makes
that was a good defense by uh marvin
good switch right there communication by
the kings getting holmes back
on jokic yeah you can hear the great
talking
and jokic silences them temporarily with
that shot
he's the problem see mark right there
you're handing it to fox they have to
respect the speed you step
one step too far milstabby kicks it back
and get hit with a three ball
milkage with the jump poke deep in the
paint four assists
mccain's shooting almost 60 percent from
the field
in this quarter jokic on the baseline
they run a nice play out of the time
rookie of the month jokic
wants white side one on one whistle foul
and counted
wow that might have been an elbow right
there elbow at the end of this let's see
we see it we'll know there it is
no doubt he is he is
must see television if you are a king's
fan
fix it to the wing michael porter jr
against robinson a good wing defender
barton with a four shot jokic got it
and puts it home and had a few words for
white side
one-on-one iso against holmes
good defense by holmes not much you can
do about that
that's a fantastic defense
deep post up by barnes and that's money
and the lead is down to eight
his numbers on the season though pretty
good 39 percent from three-point
territory jokic
drills the free-throw line jump
nine-point game
sacramento up
[Music]
12 and now 13 of his
40. jokic isolated against
holmes
with the left hand he is putting on a
clinic on the low
block burton has played 34 minutes
tonight
out of the timeout jokic firing away
man he is stunned on automatic
nobody cares and uh this is the league
where people feel sorry for you
jokic oh my goodness does not need to go
off glass
guy is not the one but you always watch
the inbounder that is for sure and he
probably got fouled to be on jokic
guarded by barnes
[Applause]
uses all 270 pounds on him and he's up
to 50 now on the meters it becomes a two
possession game
i mean great defense this is he's just a
bad man that's off the
wrong